et tu parles aussi ton
arrière-grand-mère ah ouais mais très
peu parce qu'elle a pas mon tempérament
[Musique]
4 générations de femmes une
arrière-grand-mère une grand-mère une
mère une fille en entreprenante un film
sur ce thème nous allons essayer
d'évoquer les ressemblances les
dissemblances les éventuels conflits les
points de rencontre bref les rapports
entre quatre femmes d'une même famille
et ont été élevées à une époque et dans
un contexte différent
madame Barranx elle fit avec sa mère sa
fille et sa petite fille dans sa maison
de Capbreton près de Bayonne dans les
Landes bref quatre générations de femmes
sous un même toit
[Musique]
dans la maison de Capbreton se retrouve
ainsi quotidiennement madame Lemoine
arrière-grand-mère
la grand-mère
madame Lapeyre la mer
et Florence vivait sa fille unique
vous êtes originaire de la région d'ici
mon mari est originaire de Capbreton
mais moi je suis
précisément à La Souterraine dans la
Creuse ça fait partie de la marche et de
Limousin vous avez mené vos études
jusqu'où jusqu'au
la guerre alors j'ai changé
d'orientation
j'étais comme les jeunes vous savez
j'avais beaucoup l'ambition et puis
finalement je me suis mariée en 1941
j'avais 19 ans mon mari était mobilisé
puisqu'il était aviateur je suis parti
avec lui au Maroc il a été tué en 42 28
ou 1942 j'étais donc mariée depuis 8
mois et j'attendais ma fille qui est née
six mois après l'aîné le 1er mars 1943
alors après j'étais obligé de travailler
naturellement alors je me suis tournée
vers les PTT et où j'ai fait ma carrière
ici dans cette maison vous vivez
ensemble quatre générations de femmes
quatre générations
tout à fait différents nous avons
d'ailleurs comme dans toutes les femmes
et une génération nous avons des
divergences mais enfin dans l'ensemble
vous nous entendons
je vous dis au point de vue comment
dirais-je au point de vue vie moderne
par exemple nous n'avons pas les mêmes
idées
surtout même maintenant c'est elle la
plus pour pour la vie d'autrefois elle
est plus enfin moi aussi je dirais
ministre quand je parle aussi souvent de
la vie d'autrefois ma petite fille
quelquefois quand j'en ai assez du bruit
de alors je parle à ma petite fille je
lui explique la vie d'autrefois aller me
les veiller l'autre fois vous savez que
chez mes arrières grands-parents je lui
rappelle tout ça alors et puis alors des
divergences je sais pas en point de vue
aussi musique par exemple vous avez vu
tout à l'heure à table on n'a pas les
mêmes goûts et on a pas le même carré
alors sur quel plan vous vous retrouvez
alors si vous êtes différente sur le
plan que nous nous aimons nous sommes
nous sommes différents mais je crois
qu'il y a besoin de ces différences là
pour harmoniser tout parce que il y a
des controverses et puis ce serait
monotone si nous étions toujours
d'accord et ce n'est pas quand même un
peu étouffant de vivre ensemble ainsi
constamment ou dans ce qu'il y a pas de
former un clan non non c'est à dire que
ce qui a provoqué aussi une sorte de
classe et du fait que j'ai maman a été
veuve j'étais veuve ma fille a été
divorcée alors nous nous sommes
retrouvés des femmes seules très
longtemps alors c'est ce qui a peut-être
nous a
regroupé comme ça et
[Musique]
en fait c'est vous donc qui vous occupez
sur toute votre petite fille oui c'est
moi je l'ai formé je l'ai toujours parlé
comme une grande personne c'est pour ça
que elle a évolué assez vite au point de
vue vocabulaire je lui ai jamais parlé
comme un bébé je vais toujours parler
comme une grande personne je vais
expliquer des choses même
au-dessus de sauna mais il fallait bien
c'était elle mon interlocuteur je vais
personne à qui parler alors quand
j'étais seule avec elle je la promenais
énormément elle voulait tout le temps se
promener parce qu'elle aussi elle aime
la campagne elle n'aime pas parler
c'est une petite campagne
[Musique]
donc tu viens ici alors qu'est-ce que tu
trouves qu'est-ce que tu cherches je
trouve du laurier circuler et je trouve
aussi des grottes de la ferme ça
toujours toujours puis il y a des
terriers plusieurs terriers et on se
fait les chasseurs puis aussi il y a des
champignons
[Musique]
il y a des chiens et des carottes il y a
pire délicieux quoi
quel est l'arbre que derrière toi là
c'est quoi
[Musique]
la végétation de la forêt comme ça non
j'ai l'habitude pourquoi ça te passionne
mais c'est plus intéressant la forêt des
écureuils là il y a des chevreuils
et tu sors souvent tu vas au cinéma
[Musique]
tous les dimanches je vais au restaurant
et au cinéma avec mon ami
souvent on fait du vélo on va se
prévenir des champignons pas partout
elle m'a appris beaucoup de choses elle
m'a appris la nature et tout mon papy
j'ai fait mon éducation comme ça parce
que
c'est pour ça que je suis pas là
ma petite fille elle représente
on peut pas dire tout mais enfin quelque
chose de très très fort pour moi c'est
c'est vraiment elle a beaucoup de elle a
beaucoup de caractère
nous avons les discussions mais enfin
elle a très bon coeur et
je crois que qu'elle est bien quoi
seulement je les forme et je lui ai
expliqué tout ce que je ressentais mais
je vais pas demander à elle de le
ressentir alors c'est pour ça que on
peut dire que les différents de moi
seulement je lui appris beaucoup de
choses je lui racontais des tas
d'histoires qu'elle a retenu vous savez
tout ça je l'aurais pas fait je crois
pour ma fille c'était différent d'abord
je travaillais ça te pose un problème
j'avais pas autant de liberté maintenant
je suis toujours disponible pour elle
vous a appris certaines choses
parce qu'elle m'explique beaucoup de
choses
qu'elle comprend par exemple je vous dis
sur sur la vie moderne elle m'a appris à
aimer certaines parties de la musique
moderne elle m'a appris avant je pouvais
pas supporter j'étais contre ça puis
maintenant force
je m'habitue elle me dit mamie écoute ce
disque avec moi comprendre regarde et
puis comme les lances modernes au début
j'étais con puis maintenant de l'avoir
là tu habitais je veux dire après tout
il faut tu sais c'est l'époque
derrière tout de suite quand je vais
rien
[Musique]
et puis nous nous sommes rendus dans la
Creuse à La Souterraine en compagnie de
Madame Lemoine n'arrière-grand-mère et
de sa petite fille madame Lapeyre qui a
vécu une bonne partie de son enfant
ainsi que les premières années de son
mariage
[Musique]
pour la première fois madame Lemoine
retrouvait sa maison restée dans l'état
exact où elle l'avait laissé le jour où
elle l'avait quitté quelques années
auparavant
madame Lemoigne il y a combien de temps
vous n'êtes pas venu ici
5 ans parce que j'ai été venue une fois
mais pas longtemps en ligne pour rentrer
et sortir
elle est restée longtemps avec vous ah
oui c'est moi qui l'ai loué
[Musique]
mon père était Charlot Charles forgeron
charron-sur-dothèse
cultivateurs quand j'étais jeune j'étais
chez eux beaucoup
et vous vous souvenez de votre vie
là-bas comment ça se passait quand vous
étiez à Saint-Sulpice
bien sûr je m'en souviens
j'étais bien heureuse c'est vraiment
Monsieur Michel et puis mais pour vieux
grands-parents tout ça j'étais bon pour
moi j'allais Auchan avec garder les
bêtes
je leur vends des services en même temps
ils avaient des vaches des moutons des
cochons vous préfériez vivre à la
campagne
à ce moment-là vous avez élevé vos
enfants on travaillait pas Monsieur
Michel dans le temps on travaillait pas
du tout les femmes elles restent à la
maison pour élever les gosses et puis
faire la popote
c'était plus pareil que maintenant vous
croyez que c'était mieux ah oui c'était
mieux
c'était mieux oui c'est plus maintenant
maintenant c'est comme une bande de fous
maintenant il y a plus de
c'est tout c'est tout changer la vie
c'est plus du tout comme dans le temps
j'aimais mieux la vie dans le temps à ce
moment-là mon était là tous en famille
vous comprenez c'était bien mieux que
maintenant on s'ennuyait pas
vous ennuyez maintenant
c'est pas la même vie c'est pas la même
vie de tout je le dis pas je veux pas le
dire à mes enfants mais bien sûr
Monsieur Michel que je m'ennuie
j'aimerais mieux j'aimerais mieux que
l'être là avec
tous mes souvenirs comprenez
qu'est-ce qui vous a appris à faire du
crochet ma grand-mère elle m'a appris
avec une
comment vais-je vous dire une épine de
buissant vous voyez j'ai appris comme ça
en gardant les cochons
je regardais les cochons
c'est rigolo je regarde à l'équation ma
grand-mère m'a envoyé elle tu sais ne
les laisse pas partir la moitié du temps
je les laisse pas
vous avez appris à votre fille votre
petite fille des choses que votre mère
ou votre grand-mère vous avez apprise
elles peuvent pas elles peuvent pas
faire de crochets
Madeleine ne peut pas non plus ah non
c'est plus la main c'est plus comme dans
le temps
dans le temps on avait plaisir à faire
tout ça monsieur Michel à apprendre à
voir des choses comme ça maintenant non
non
beaucoup de pour tout ma grand-mère
m'avait appris à faire beaucoup de
choses je travaillais très bien mes
doigts je faisais beaucoup de choses
d'ailleurs encore elles ont besoin de
moi elle a besoin de moi magasin pour
faire les quand il y a quelque chose à
la course
c'est la mamie la mémé qu'il fait ma
mère elle savait moins tout ça elle
était surtout dans la maison pour le
ménage la cuisine tout ça elle savait
pas aussi bien que ma grand-mère
j'aimais mieux ma grand-mère j'aimais
bien ma mère mais j'aimais mieux ma
grand-mère vous voyez c'est drôle là
voilà j'ai reçu beaucoup de mes arrières
grands-mères et tout qui me racontait
des histoires j'ai reçu beaucoup de
choses sur la vie d'autrefois que
j'aurais pas appris dans des livres quoi
parce que il se passait des choses
autrefois je me souviens mon
arrière-grand-mère arrière-grand-mère
avait vu des loups dans la Creuse vous
savez il y a un bois alors ça je elle me
racontait ça parce que le soir les
aïeuls parlaient beaucoup il y avait pas
autre chose à faire alors elle a veillée
il vous racontait des tas de choses et
alors ça m'a
ça m'a fait quelque chose ça m'a appris
beaucoup de choses aussi la façon dont
les gens vivaient et que la vie était
beaucoup plus difficile les gens étaient
beaucoup plus économes parce que il
n'avait pas de retraite il n'avait vous
savez comment est allé les personnes à
cette époque-là et tout ça je l'ai
retenu ça m'a laissé quelques principes
[Musique]
avec le recul comment voyez-vous votre
enfant ici comment s'est-elle passée
j'étais très heureuse j'ai toujours été
très heureuse j'aimais beaucoup la
Creuse
j'avais de très bons souvenirs pendant
mon enfance bien sûr maintenant ce n'est
pas pareil mais
lorsque j'étais petite j'étais vraiment
très heureuse ici et lorsque vous
habitiez avec votre grand-mère elle vous
parlait de la façon dont vivait c'est
ses parents ses grands-parents ah oui
oui et elle j'allais souvent avec elle à
Saint-Sulpice les feuilles quitte à 14
km d'ici nous partions toutes les deux
en vélo
partir le matin nous allions voir mes
arrières grands-parents nous rentrons le
soir
[Musique]
et vous étiez disons aussi unique par
exemple vous êtes actuellement les
quatre générations à ce moment là aussi
tout le temps
nous nous ennuyons quand nous ne sommes
pas ensemble
et vous avez été donc éduqué pendant 11
ans par votre grand-mère vous pensez que
votre mère dans cette période vous aurez
éduqué de la même façon non certainement
pas certainement pas si ça avait été ma
mère
à quel niveau aura été la différence
simplement au niveau de l'instruction
bon j'ai quand même une très très bonne
instruction si vous avez été avec ma
mère ça aurait été différent ma mère
m'aurait poussé beaucoup plus dans les
études
vous souhaitez que votre fille travaille
je pense que qu'à notre époque une femme
doit quand même
subvenir à ses besoins aussi et avoir
son indépendance alors je trouve que
c'est tout à fait normal qu'elle est une
situation est-ce que vous pensez pour
vous aussi oui je pense c'est parce que
si je n'avais pas eu de situation
comment aurais-je fait pour élever ma
fille parce que je me suis trouvé je me
suis trouvé toute seule pour l'élever ce
que vous savez ce sont pas les pensions
alimentaires actuellement qui vous
permettent
d'élever convenablement un enfant si tu
as des enfants tu voudrais rester à la
maison pour les élever ou tu préférerais
travailler
moi je veux faire vétérinaire j'aime
beaucoup les animaux c'est pour ça j'ai
deux chiens une chienne qui s'appelle
Ondine à 13h les grognon celle-là oulala
et Isis
mais tu crois qu'on peut qu'on peut
lever aussi bien des enfants en étant
pas à la maison
je sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais si vous n'étiez pas obligé de
travailler est-ce que vous aimeriez
votre fille vous-même
oui bien sûr enfin là je l'ai très
souvent
je ne nous la partager avec maman je les
trois fois par semaine entièrement et je
l'ai tous les midis et tous les soirs je
suis avec elle c'est à dire que
simplement quand je le rentre me coucher
je rentre me coucher chez moi c'est tout
est-ce que vous arrive de partir de
temps en temps vous par exemple quand
même et je suis parti pour la première
fois cette année toute seule partie très
loin
j'ai téléphoné j'étais à 12000 km mais
j'ai téléphoné parce que je m'ennuyais
qu'est-ce que vous cherchez en étant
ainsi Unis un sentiment de sécurité un
peu je crois j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose de toute façon ni ma mère ni ma
grand-mère ne m'empêchons de faire au
contraire elle m'aime beaucoup et
même beaucoup plus ouvert parce que
lorsque j'ai envie de partir lorsque
j'ai envie d'aller faire mes achats et
tout je sais que ma fille est en
sécurité risque si je la confie à
quelqu'un d'autre ça pas pareil
et comment envisagez-vous d'être un jour
grand mère ou arrière-grand-mère
peut-être ah si j'étais ailleurs un
grand miroir
j'essaierai de rendre service à ma fille
aussi si elle a besoin de moi je
garderai ses enfants
à qui pensait vous que vous
ressembleriez le plus alors à votre mère
ou votre grand-mère
parce que
c'est pas ma grand-mère c'était pas
pareil
ma grand-mère répète plusieurs fois la
même chose tandis que maman quand tu as
dit quelque chose elle le dit elle ne se
répète pas plusieurs fois ma grand-mère
est charmante mais elle répète trop et
tu parles aussi ton arrière-grand-mère
ah ouais mais très peu parce qu'elle a
pas mon tempérament
mais quand tu arrives de parler avec
elle tu parles un peu de la vie
d'autrefois avec elle
aujourd'hui votre arrière petite fille
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait ça me fait
beaucoup de peine monsieur ça me fait
beaucoup de peine parce que je sais pas
si ma petite fille pensera à moi quand
je serai morte comme moi je pense au
mien je crois pas elle est très mignonne
là mais c'est pas la même chose
elle est très mignonne ça elle est très
mignonne beaucoup je l'aime plus que
tout Monsieur Michel je l'aime plus que
ma fille vous voyez comme c'est comment
devient et plus que ma petite fille elle
c'est mon arrière petite fille je l'aime
plus qu'elles autres vous voyez mais je
pense la nuit quand je leur parle je dis
quand même elle me regrettera pas le
passera même pas à moi c'est plus du
tout la même mentalité c'est plus comme
dans le temps on était trop attaché au
vieux là le temps comprenez alors je me
dis ça et ça ne travaille ça me rend
malade aussi que souhaitez-vous le plus
pour votre arrière petite fille ah je
lui souhaite qu'elle réussisse qu'elle
soit vétérinaire comme elle veut
puisqu'elle veut ça qu'elle fasse tout
pour être vétérinaire c'est ce qui lui
plaît et alors qu'elle réussisse bien
mais je voudrais pas qu'elle se marie
faudrait qu'elle reste fille et pourquoi
ça ah parce que sa mère a tellement
souffert Monsieur Michel et puis
Madeleine aussi elle a beaucoup souffert
de son mariage son mari qui est mort
comme ça la guerre et vous croyez pas
que c'est normal qu'une fille se marie
pourtant Michel mais moi je suis vieux
jeu je dis elle serait peut-être plus
heureuse avec son métier se promener
voyager puis faire son métier
[Musique]
vous souhaiteriez travailler en mer
oui oui
les enfants de ma petite fille
pensait que ça vous apporterait autant
que d'être grand-mère oui peut-être même
encore plus on vieillit vous savez plus
plus on aime les jeunes les enfants moi
j'aime beaucoup la jeunesse moi
d'ailleurs je savais je ne la critique
pas
je trouve que là de jeunesse a beaucoup
de difficultés je les comprends très
très bien parce que je les approfondis
je ne suis pas pour le ceux qui
critiquent la jeunesse moi je suis pas
contre
même quand tu seras plus grande on fera
peut-être si tu te maries ou si tu vas
faire des études plus loin faudra
peut-être que tu ailles habiter ailleurs
elle est restée elle les a pas de
abandonnés alors moi je fais pareil
parce que je suis pas faux
[Musique]